welcome back to cbs this morning
cbs news is investigating claims about
the troubling way
hundreds of veterans were allegedly
treated at one v.a
medical center insiders say the problem
was ignored even after it was brought to
light
in an exclusive interview interview a
whistleblower told us
the v.a medical center in new orleans
failed to properly evaluate veterans
for traumatic brain injuries for years
and said the results were tragic
our chief investigative correspondent
jim axelrod joins us
with part two of this incredibly
powerful report jim good morning
good morning anthony yesterday we told
you about a whistleblower who says
veterans did not get the care they
needed
for what the va itself calls the
signature wound of combat
in afghanistan and iraq this morning
something even more alarming what
insiders say happened when the doctors
in charge
were confronted he had his gun
on his chest and he would pull it to his
head he'd pull it down
he'd pull it to his head he'd pull it
down she's the wife of an iraq war vet
who threatened suicide how close were
you to pulling that trigger
i was very close i mean i was convinced
that it would be the best thing
for everyone they asked we conceal their
identities
fearing retaliation from the v.a the vet
who says he suffered
five knocked out blows during the
invasion in 2003
first sought treatment at the new
orleans va in 2011
diagnosed with ptsd his wife said her
husband's issues
went far beyond psychological trauma
he's in physical pain 24 7 to the point
that he wants to end his life because he
wants the pain to end
when he screened positive for a possible
tbi at the va in new orleans
they were hopeful but they say he never
got the mandated follow-up
that would have provided a formal
diagnosis and treatment plan
for a physical injury and it's
heartbreaking to watch him at home
suffer the way he suffers because he
feels like he's not doing enough
he's not trying hard enough opposed to
baby
this is biological is this more than a
set of symptoms
in 2017 va psychologist dr frederick
sotter
started to see more and more cases like
this he dug into the data and
something didn't add up the new orleans
va
was diagnosing tbi at about one-quarter
the national rate
there were fifteen hundred that really
needed to be looked at
so dr sauter compiled the list of vets
who he says screened positive for a
possible tbi in new orleans
but never got the follow-up what did you
then do with the list
i found the people who treat tbi and it
was a list
compiled of veterans who basically had
just
slipped through the cracks nurse
priscilla pelche was on the team
tasked with treating tbi at the new
orleans va
there was absolutely no treatment being
provided to them
she and her team pitched a plan to her
boss
contact vets on the list and bring them
in for reevaluation
she says his response was unbelievable
that is not our concern lose the list
i'm sorry what were the last three words
lose the list
essentially you're a health care
provider and you're asking to provide
care for veterans who hadn't been cared
for
instead you're shut down correct how
could we not try
to do something that's why we're there
that's why we're there
we took an oath i took an oath when i
became a nurse
the doctor who priscilla peltier says
ordered her to lose the list
dr robert meatbro is the head of
rehabilitation services here at this va
hospital in new orleans
we wanted to hear what dr meapro had to
say about how this va
handles tbis but he declined our request
for an on-camera interview
after part one of our investigation
aired yesterday hello dr mipro
we went to dr meebrow's home we
identified ourselves
can we ask you a couple questions but he
was still unwilling to speak to us
what is he doing working at the va i
don't know
should he be from what i know no these
problems don't happen unless there's
people who are allowing it to happen
sauter pressed the va to investigate in
a report
never made public but obtained by cbs
news the va
found new orleans failed to provide
appropriate care
to those veterans with positive initial
screening for tbi
the report called for the va to ensure
vets who did not get proper follow-up
receive additional screening and
treatment did
anybody from the va ever contact you and
say you fell
through the cracks come on back negative
it's a farce you know they're
our nations heroes who deserve
the best care you know you're going into
some bureaucracy when you enter
nothing could prepare you for just how
bad how blatantly incredibly
bad the denial of care is
in a statement to cbs news the v.a says
it quote
did follow all of the recommendations
outlined in the report
and that dr robert meepro has the full
confidence and support of the leadership
team
nurse priscilla peltier resigned and
filed a complaint claiming she was
retaliated against for refusing to lose
the list
her claim failed but she plans to refile
as for the whistleblower dr fred sotter
he retired from the va last month in
frustration
after a nearly 30-year career
gail oh boy jim i don't even know what
to say you told us yesterday
and i thought yesterday was bad by the
way with what you unveiled to us
yesterday was bad you said wait till
today and you certainly now i feel it's
a one-two punch veterans who have served
and
served in this country should never just
fall through the cracks it ought to be a
right this way how can we help you this
is so disheartening and so upsetting to
hear
i think that's something we can all
agree on yep more people need to see
that story thank you very much jim